hands compress my name's welcome to
akinator I'm sure you heard of it before
it's supposed to be but for those of you
don't know this [ __ ] right here
just look at that [ __ ] he can guess
by asking you questions whoever you're
thinking about it's supposed to be
impossible but I think we can put this
to the test
I'm not gonna say one thinking about so
you brothers can play along I don't know
if your that will make sense but let's
do this think about a real or fictional
character I will try and guess who it is
my my age or okay my age it's your
character male yes it's your character
youtuber hey now now I don't know what
you going on about it isn't actually no
it's a character real no has your
character ever been in a movie uh I
don't remember his name I gotta look up
[ __ ] uh probably it's your character
animated dammit I don't like this is
your character an animal no is your does
your character often wear a hat no it's
your character from a Japanese
yes miss your character black-haired no
it's your character bad no it's a
character the main character yes he's
your character blond yes is the
character can you know is you care to
work with the group probably is a
character an American girl don't know
it's your character missing parts of
their body
no no hi how how did he know that
Wow oh okay this is a good one it's your
character real yes from YouTube probably
is a cake
how ha get out of my head does your
character ride on a giant well he should
be
mr. characters he's asking a lot of
[ __ ] questions does your character
know zoe sugg what the [ __ ] is that
probably does your character sometimes
work with beautifier yes ed yeah what
the [ __ ] how do they know that I'm so
surprised now I'm gonna have to dig deep
to the darkest places of the internet
I'm not gonna tell you what I'm thinking
about man if he gets that if he gets
that okay I'm gonna try something really
[ __ ] weird
have you seen your character naked how
how how how how how how is your
character less than 25 years old oh hell
no
that is [ __ ] how do they know that in
14 questions oh my god that's ridiculous
okay I got it there's no [ __ ] way he
can know this yes no no probably yes no
yes before was inside
what kind of question is that
does your character drink their own
urine ah probably is your character a
beat no okay it doesn't seem like she
can guess it but he's really close I was
going for Blackie Goku
you